hello welcome to this video I'm trying
one of those bullets tournaments on
bleach s where is that can I do this
Oh what already has started I how do I
join here one bullet okay okay I have to
start I'm really not really not used to
that haven't played bullet at all
recently time would be an issue
especially as that is three zero it's
not 1+1 or something is really doable
for me quite all the time
one zero I Evers who yeah tricky yeah I
look followed up here which is nice and
he just blunder the second one but still
you have to win first and I'm somewhat
ahead on the clock here but it still
nots not that easy I have to use pre
moves quite quite a bit come on let's
let's get those pawns rolling
yeah okay I think I will manage I really
not playing this often here so I don't
really know what this buzzer King and
stuff really well but I think if I want
to do this I have to have to do it
before the turn before the game I mean
so nothing to worry about
yep response I should blunder one of
them it's not a good idea
and I shouldn't shouldn't still meet him
that's also to be avoided okay so white
is victorious that's me
return to tournament Wow does this work
I don't see a double points I've got two
points okay whatever it hits me why is
this my system one hour long I only have
time for 30 minutes that's that's a
problem okay we have some kind of ratty
system here we're not much happens
it's very equal ish
okay maybe Knight to f5 that would be
noise don't get it okay I'm taking all
this gaining some time yeah let's gain a
little bit of space I have to be ready
for before yep managed okay like this
yeah it's kind of equal - of course
the problem here is the time it's about
equal at the moment can I do something
okay let's regroup here for a five do do
something here okay stays pretty pretty
much equal oh I've given up this it's
not good
one move one move I just was just about
playing 93 okay the problem is here
relieve Isis this is nonsense lasting
one hour those tournaments those
tournaments should be 30 minutes why is
that okay I'll see what I can do but
this is kind of annoying I really wanted
to finish the event and now I cannot do
this really anyway maybe yeah that's a
queen buddy
Oh a queen okay yeah I think you need
you need some kind of some kind of
strike here to get to get real points or
velocities justice is really a high
rated person
okay no he's quick he should be with
that name yeah position is okay
threatening night f4
cannot go g5 unfortunately he also had
c4 which was even stronger didn't want
that Oh Queen trade is not exactly
helping okay I can resign this yeah well
I don't really play any bullet so
job I'm in the middle of the field
really only not playing any any role but
lost such a chest was very strong though
I mean everything went wrong they had
the whole opening everything and yeah
this is a very nice position with this
with those traits already in I can be
very satisfied just wanna pawn here
second pawn maybe you cannot enter I
believe yes I have to do this and now
rook e8 is coming okay h5 and then look
at five Andrew can you five
and now I'm going here and pick up that
porn a force coming come on
f 1 and H 1 come on let's pick up the
pants now
no II to hopes I'm taking a while don't
win quickly I'm glad to win at all
that's really the first Buddha chess for
ages like that pseudo night
can I preserve here from more points
it's got 1600 oh I already have 28
seconds so this is crazy with the
berserk Inge it's really crazy
25 seconds how is how is is possible
even and this guy is actually playing
well that is the biggest issue
okay that that was nice for me
maybe I should have taken there under
1c3 that's not bad oh yeah oh I cannot
shake him
oops oops oops oops you got five seconds
ah Oh is resigned he resigned earlier
two seconds left
who so I got some points 14th place
accurate okay let's get going
what he took 1c3
and blended just blended the Queen in
one move and their pre moved of course
unbelievable stuff
great
so just pawned for just a piece down
here right amazing had this is the
nonsense that you really have to hate in
Bullitt says they blunder everything and
it doesn't matter because you had a pre
move in and of course the only premiums
that Weekly made any sense I mean okay
so maybe I can still cause some trouble
here but really
it's not particularly quick but my
position really sucks I mean really
oh I can take this one on time yeah that
is that's bullet chess for you
bah look whoever that is okay that
somewhat playable at least it's my move
why it's my move
ah yeah I'm not used to this side and
I'm not used to bullet and both things
in addition can be tricky he might be
able to sacrifice on his sixer it could
be an idea just playing
normal-looking moves here trying to get
that porn didn't
takes Luke cheeks is really awful okay
let's get step to the side I can check
here how takes takes Queen d7 maybe g4
is hanging it's not so easy now okay
this
oh it's made oh okay oh wow yeah at
least I'd like to be on the first page
of it that would be nice but you really
have to be somewhat what like resigned
okay for whatever reason number 10 so
I'm not I mean I'm I'm I'm yeah not in
good shape but here there here we go
okay Casey in the house he's definitely
got more bullet practice than I have I
have none
okay and position is nice but it doesn't
mean much
can I go to see - yep this but I can I
can push this away Queen h4 I need this
no okay
probably 4c - hmm so if I take here
taking five is so bad
I don't know what this is
I'm taking you five now just taking this
okay so I'm totally winning but who
knows
you need to still need some bullet
skills to be somewhat quick here
actually one more time okay so one win
at least my problem is still it don't
have time for this event
freak lot eat loads whatever very high
rating
okay some kind of offbeat opening I
didn't really manage to to reviewed it
or anything but it's it's an okay
position I hope it's slightly better
it's not it's not terrible or anything
but he is better and he constantly does
not play what I expect him to play which
is annoying in the long run yeah
positions position is totally fine
I is playing this for loss but time time
witness the idea
okay a draw I only have five seconds
position is probably winning but I don't
know maybe I could have tried actually
okay ninth place I'm still very much
behind this guy is constantly scoring -
ah
yep the ice is getting this kind of
attack yonder on the kingside I have to
try to be annoying there yep straight
this
no maybe here trading Queens would be
absolutely helpful if I can manage that
okay I can open up the center now that's
interesting that is somewhat risky at
least hmm
okay let's do this
good night III coming camp remover and
94 is still kind of annoying
I came so that looks okay
promoting this oh he was at I'm really
not very much used to the way this is
handled him that's a very nice position
all of the Kings Indian attack very very
nice for white actually getting good
good attack here on the kingside oops
no Knight f3 of course cinema slip it's
maybe still okay but I know he gets if I
have any other position that was already
almost lost for black if I don't mouse
slip there
we'd have a shame really so what about
this now Queeny six is the idea and the
rook is hanging it should be nice
actually
don't okay so I'm meeting him okay I was
a nice one with no time okay so I'm on
seventh place kind of getting closer
yeah let's just develop I've got an
extra pawn which is noise even though
it's not clear or anything oh no it gets
better I'm taking this yeah that's nice
it's a nice position it's really just
the pawn and not much else
hmm okay maybe I can get in
yeah I can get in c4 let's do that just
push push forward here walk c5 or Bishop
eight six maybe let's prevent mmm yeah
let's go Bishop a6 get rid of this and
then see if I can get to B - and no more
the Queen was offering it away I didn't
really think of the Greens right here he
had offered the Queen Street didn't
think of this of course at all okay it's
some adventures here so I'm kind of
close here at least something let's do
some pure bullet style can I get to h6
with Mike you eating okay I can do this
with the temple maybe I can get to h6
let's go here
yeah I can take this takes 25 should be
a win
first-first a couple of chicks and now
this one and cancels for Luke age one
mate can pre move that at supreme okay
return to tournament 31 points okay
enough not that far away even though I'm
not doing too well but I'm scoring a
little bit at least velocity chest so
ever is really strong I really don't
know who that is
okay kissy again okay I've got some kind
of maroc see boiled
which obviously I like like to see maybe
Queen to b6 or something okay let's take
their let's do this got a good control
oh yeah h3 this is typical bullet style
just try something objectively this is
totally totally bad for black but
anything can happen in this time control
of course
Bishop c4 was winning the Queen but now
could have done that earlier okay so
third place
AHA the thing is I have at one point you
will hear some sound and this is my this
is my my dinner it's in though and then
there's in the oven and it would have
been perfect for a 30-minute event but
not for this type of event yeah this is
this bad Lloyd well it's of course
rather tricky in in bullet
it is awful for white but of course
total messy - total mess so let's take
this and develop and hope that it works
Queen was taking their main goal is not
to blunder something in one move which
can easily happen and this guy is of
course tricky I mean he's really high
rated down now I'm already I already
have spoiled this White has got a nice
position now
can take f3 though what is he doing here
and who should be fired
he's got no check I think I got him yeah
that was nice okay so at least I got
this one winnin the problem is really at
one point and I said there will be a
sound from my kitchen and I have to
attend to my my my food and what can I
do I was thinking it's it's it's a 30
minute event how quick is this guy I
mean it's very bad but it's also very
quick okay that's a piece almost but
it's it's a terrible position okay let's
let's take everything here
and even go back and keep stuff
and now he's spending time when he's got
everything lost already okay come on a
shaky 96 made maybe this is happening
almost yeah we have 6 next ok feet
okay I'm leading this event I can't
believe it
playing keys again okay
funny Oh No
I'll slip okay very necessary 27 minutes
left
oops what happened here
I wanted to talk and [ __ ] okay let's
let's get that game going
I'll kill us a typical bullet opening
for black it's pushing everything
forward okay don't believe in this
really I have Brooke h1 okay I can do
this it's immediate move
yeah and white is totally winning
but it's bullet of course
this
ninety seven would be nice to get in 194
for winning of the f5 pawn yep
check
really 97 of corrupted to as well I
worked it - it's not helping me okay I
can shake first and then see what
happens
anyway f5 is also hanging
that's a bit much as the cheeks e7o
that's made okay IRA Lhasa tea-chest is
kind of snob that dominated name group
not that dominating anymore as he was
earlier just trying to be quick here for
once
yeah got a slightly better structure oh
no it's a piece I like pieces give me
pieces okay yeah better secure this yeah
Oh
ticking wasn't proved was not great
could have played you for anyway yeah
okay well in this this also gives me
chances Petrucci 127 now okay for the
fork made on f7 teeth now threatened
will be difficult Oh didn't react to it
okay
23 minutes I have no idea how long that
thing is still in the oven
LM let's stream okay and not sure how
good an idea that was going into some
kind of end game against someone who is
constantly playing those events maybe
not the greatest idea no Matt five I
wanted to play f5 of course g5 is
totally ridiculous funny oh I can take
this it takes an age six let's pin pin
and win that's always nice and it will
be very nice for me in terms of mating
chances okay now I can take this take
here
now you resigned okay I'm not doing that
badly kind of getting in stride about 95
points here run Deb
okay let's just develop stuff hope for
the best
here we go if I've what are you doing
mr. Wang Deb 95 for the threads oh I
couldn't couldn't just yeah it was
wasn't so bad what he did okay let's go
to the side yeah not much I have to they
cannot get rid of this bloody pin
shoot cannot get rid of this amazing
okay now now the worst is over in terms
of directly losing I hope I can't grab
this this and maybe open up stuff
somehow okay at least this King is wide
open dark squares f5 now is a threat
check okay at least is good wait I have
to be cautious
no mate please I know it's it's a pure
time time matter
that guy's quicker than I am probably
yep he was quicker yeah you really you
need the experience on the side and the
the general speed him and I like both at
the moment
yeah that's Casey again and this is the
position I like I've got very nice
control here that's the most important
thing against him in particular that you
have things under control and he cannot
do anything crazy to you if he gets to
do crazy things he's strong he really is
and this is nice now but not winning
this is this is now I guess winning take
there or take there I don't know yes
this this weird discovery maybe use this
as well how is he covering f6 he guess
he isn't now he's got no discovery
full of g7 let's take it so it's a whole
look and I've got more time
okay and I got some good games they've
got the odd good game but of course I'm
not
for Brian and Casey Wow that's funny
with no love for Cee right okay I'm not
playing on leeches oh I understand that
I'm not mentioned okay let's see if I
can get this pawn back yep I managed
okay I'll go get the Knight to e5 I
guess yep
Abby should be v was good no I didn't do
that okay no night for is a threat to
nowhere let's regroup for the e6 pawn
and night h4 would win okay I'm taking
this pawn yeah I have a rather technical
bullet style and I need some needs I
need to be somewhat quick and this is
some sometimes lacking here I'm trying
to usually win by not blundering stuff
and picking up stuff and you have to win
16 minutes quite sure what what about my
food must must ring any minute actually
I'm not mistaken but I think I can
finish this I mean it's probably maybe I
have to quickly jump over there and make
sure it's not totally killed by that by
the heat but I think I can complete the
event pretty fibers hanging
Charlie waffles whoever that is okay at
least I got some activity here it's not
not that bad I mean for being upon down
relatively speaking before would have
been interesting okay maybe I still get
to you for 93 94 and then I'm not even
worse here rather rather the opposite
okay that's nice now white is better
here in this position timewise I'm okay
endgame is of course very nice
let's grab p3
actually why not this I'm essentially
playing with extra points here lots of
them
he's completely blocked down no mouse
slip unfortunately it wasn't that
terrible okay how and how now to win now
there should be some win hmm I played it
badly actually I played I didn't play it
well this I now the bloody time they
won't give me that he completely
outplayed himself and then I screwed it
up on time shoot that was very much
unnecessary but there's no it's the
bloody clock fourteen minutes how can I
avoid to get a games possibility no I
have to play with LA City chess with
that damn clock clock beeping all the
time it's fun I think it actually never
stops you really have to go there and
stop it no position is fantastic
actually
it's more or less winning for white
the damn clock great yeah as I said I
was thinking it's it's a shorter event
but it's it's one hour all of a sudden
okay how do I get there
to age five
it's the way to get there don't see it
at the moment maybe doubling on the G
file I can actually take and take aged
six just simple stuff take here and I
could just go back why not I strapped
her so I will win a second time against
him
I hope at least and not blundering stuff
okay between g7 is pre move mate yep so
I got some good games and um can I
oh it did it stopped beeping but I have
to take this thing out of the oven okay
yeah like did move so sepal gotta win
yeah nothing to do I really had to make
sure that this food is not completely
completely completely burnt it is
already kind of darkish I saw it and
that was a bad opening but okay that
that running running for the food is not
exactly helpful so what's this I'm kind
of underdeveloped here okay I have to
play the end game then
who is this actually cootie brief not a
player I know he has special p3 okay but
he didn't use that opportunity it's
gained a little bit of space there
well I've been a bit quicker
I could have could have gone to the same
Ranga why didn't I do that I don't
already know should have done that
really okay I'm trying to be a little
bit more active here and this otherwise
pretty boring position yep he took care
of that one
okay let's approach yeah little bit okay
now g6 is falling
check yeah okay so what is left like ten
minutes he glued did I think I played
him right now he has a very strong run
here at the end for Brian Keyes Casey
again okay oh no I don't want to do this
after see three
hmm what was that to go he took a while
to play that simple move I could have
played rook e8 huh that would have been
much better actually robbing him of
canceling rights okay that's not too bad
either
yep I'm taking this okay so maybe I get
third place maybe I can get third place
in this event eight minutes left and I'm
really hungry by now
I got no game I'd outrun Deb
come on so no maybe I can build up some
f4 based attack here this is quite
dangerous often in bullet chess those
kind of direct attacks yeah I was just
I'm just going for it here hope that
this is as dangerous as it looks can go
to e7 so I have to probably open up open
up the position more that's just fire
here and hope for the best can take this
check of course I can kick f8 the whole
time but I want to he wants to check
here right so let's do this thing so you
want to click on g3 I want more pieces
involved it's kind of awful to play it's
just some kind of win I don't see it at
the moment
Oh long diagonal I'm killing myself here
probably I have 94 though so nothing bad
is happening if that should be some kind
of wind please
yep okay so I got dead women and I'm
Lucia third place six minutes left our
bloodstream twitches as one of the
direct opposition there one of the guys
competing nice so yeah I made an opening
blunder already not a blunder is a bit
strong but okay this is not that
terrible now I can go away for
hmm opposite colored bishops here
that's an interesting position question
is really who strikes first I don't want
him to sacrifice the exchange oops what
is this so what seems I'm winning I
don't really know what happened there I
think it seems he simply didn't
recapture or something like that okay so
I'm on I'm really a third place but a
Blitzen goosy goosy
what can we do here against boozie
boozie like very quick if you try for
very cheap pre moves they will
definitely see that it wasn't that was
admittedly very very cheap
yeah purely technical game but I was
quick really lots of Primos doesn't seem
like i'm losing on time
threatening Luke b8 oh yeah oh yeah
give me that Bishop please resigned I'd
like at least one one more game yes so
I've got eight points ahead of number
four yeah that should be enough really
er or not that's truth I guess the truth
so maybe some kind of a good Indian set
up can I trade that Bishop that would be
nice chick and jump right in attacking
d3 funny enough okay let's do this and
see if we can open up the position for
us you put it straight it's already
quite awkward for a white you know okay
might be five is kind of annoying okay
didn't do that yeah I want to be ready
to take the night if it appears
somewhere
yeah it looks looks okay now only moved
to fears rookie six and he's not doing
that
you've got a huge advantage on the clock
position is also nice one minute
something left when for just four points
ahead in front of dialogue gives me the
Queen that's nice
okay so that's eight points again I
think it that should be a third place
that's nice I really had a rotten start
yeah you can still see that yeah but
then it was kind of okay ish I had one
or two bad Mouse lips
I got Casey again got three out of three
in this event against them till now yeah
just playing very simple chess here try
to play against his bishop on g2 which
is not doing that much okay I cannot
take it was a good shot
oops and maybe I get in ninety five
years I get in 95 this could be five to
solidify this haha I didn't didn't see
that one coming
it's not good not threatening much here
actually hey I can take it
I don't really have anything I think I
have to check and hope for the best here
like with Queen III stuff like that it's
not really quick at least compared to
what he can do sometimes right age for
thread g5 is prevented maybe I can get
that horn let's let me give that let me
take that pawn yes he had if he had
Ruger six okay
I won on time ha ha ha he won on time
unbelievable anyway so I am caught I've
got third place right I cannot return to
tournament now but it is on zero zero
zero how do I get back there if I click
there yeah third place and I actually
won 119 points this is quite a quite a
bit berserk win rate is 33% for 3
o'clock that's crazy
yeah I really don't I don't really know
when to do it when to not I don't know
ok anyway I hope you enjoyed that it was
kind of funny with my with my kitchen
clock and everything and I really have
dinner now thanks for watching